that was weird hey
boss who are you the name's neona and
how did you who yeah sick
arm I'm Troy quain one of the directors
of neona how you doing I'm Nick Bruno
and this is neona with scenes at the
Academy
shelter moner attack
monster immediate shelter we are so
excited to share two of the most pivotal
and emotional scenes of our film monster
this particular scene was a difficult
one for Troy and I are you okay I don't
want to talk about it this was one of
the first scenes we wrote we knew that
this was going to be foundational to the
journey of this character and ultimately
the themes of this film and it's this
idea of this powerful shape-shifting
character who could be anything she
wants but at the end of the day all she
wants is to be seen and accepted and yet
she lives in a kingdom where all of the
Hidden messaging and overt messaging is
kill anything different kill anything
monstrous did you see the way that
little girl looked at me you see over
her shoulder ballister taking that in
you see his shoulders drop you see his
head drop you realize he's hearing this
and feeling culpable they grew up
believing that they can be a hero if
they drive a sword Into the Heart of
anything different he was one of those
people who thought if I could just
become a knight if I could fight a
this Kingdom that has kind of turned its
back on me will accept me as well and in
that moment he's feeling the weight and
the guilt and the truth in neon's words
and I'm the
monster the graphic novel has connected
with so many people because of the lgbtq
plus themes and when we started working
on this movie we knew we were going to
shine a light on that I know something's
wrong I said I don't want to talk about
it hey I'm just trying to help I don't
need your help
this is such an important scene it's
where ballister and neon's thematic
philosophies change hands for the whole
movie ballister has been saying if I can
get back to the Institute and they see
me as a knight they'll accept me you
know and neona is like once people made
their mind up about you there's nothing
you can do you just are the thing they
see you as they only see you one way no
matter how hard you try and that's been
their sort of thematic argument all the
way through to the movie at this point
and it's at this moment where ballister
gives any he says you're right I've been
fighting it but you've been right all
along you were right about everything
The Institute the
wall
ambrosious no matter what we do we can't
change the way people see us for pona
now here's someone who's changed their
mind on her you changed the way you see
me and if that's possible didn't you
maybe more is possible maybe we could
change more minds and so you watch in
what starts as this incredibly somber
introspective scene pick up an energy
and a sense of hope and a sense of
purpose between between these two
characters who flopped thematically
during this conversation we shouldn't
have to
run and you made a deal right we clear
your name you make me your Sidekick and
you can't back out on a deal because you
believe in truth and honor and blah blah
blah all that stupid stuff truth and on
on stupid but all right one of the
greatest things about animation is you
have control over everything and it's so
much fun to animate and move things
around and if you look closely in this
scene we didn't do any of that
because the scene we want you to listen
if you watch you see there's a little
bit of energy that carries through what
was a crazy sequence before these
characters come to a standstill and they
just
talk I don't know what's
scarier the fact that everyone in this
Kingdom wants to run a sword through my
heart or that some sometimes
times I just want to let them our
instructions to animators were do
nothing which is really hard to do
sometimes same thing with the cameras
our goal is for you to listen to these
characters it was really important for
them to hit the right pose the right
feeling see some thought process in
their eyes to really make sure that the
emotions coming across that they're
thinking they're actively listening now
we talk about Shadow and light a lot in
this movie and we very purposefully put
this one shaft of light coming from the
ceiling between them at the beginning of
the sequence they're both still in the
shadow separated by this sense of
acceptance and it's not until Baler goes
over to the Shelf he turns on that light
after he said together together suddenly
this monochromatic scene shifts to one
with more color and they both step
forward into that colorful light as this
idea of them coming together of them
accepting each other of them becoming a
team so you got a plan of course I got a
plan something something something
we
[Music]
win I've been a professional artist for
20 years this is the thing I'm most
proud of being a part of is this one
scene I'm proud of all the people that
we worked with to put this together we
strive for authenticity and we were
moved by so many people just saying that
at some point when life is hard when
you've been an outsider for so long
sometimes it's so hard to move on with
life we were afraid as directors to go
there this is still a family movie and
it was like is that okay can you do that
it seems very heavy but every time we
didn't do it somebody was saying that
you're missing a big part of that truth
and when we did do it it brought us to
tears to be very
honest the statue of glor with sword
outstretched for the whole movie has
been a symbol of being a hero and in
this one moment ballister shows the
kingdom what it means to truly be a hero
not with a sword outstretched in fact he
throws his sword away but with a hand
out stretched and a quest for
forgiveness I'm sorry he does that in
front of everybody and it was important
for us to hear those words echoed I'm
sorry on the Jumbotron so the populace
could hear the conversation
there's very few words in this entire
sequence in fact it plays musically for
the most part incredible score by
Kristoff
[Music]
Beck both Chloe Grace morett and rized
they really were truly the heart and
soul of this film I'm sorry the big
reason why we chose them is because they
in their own communities are fighting
for acceptance what are
you I'm nimona they came in and they
didn't just make their characters fun
and deliver good acting
[Music]
performances they truly knew the source
material pona what's it all really for
and what we were all trying to say
because they've lived it they felt it
and I think that really comes
across we see the little girl who had
originally held the sword up to
pneumonia in the crowd taking a
tentative step from the shadow that
she's in and when she sees pona
transforming she steps fully out of that
shadow and she becomes to proxy for this
idea of we're not hiding anymore we're
not afraid of what we saw is different
we're getting to see pona in a new light
because of ballister's actions it allows
her to step forward in light and
understand what's really happening
[Music]
color is such an important part of our
storytelling and you know some people
catch it some people don't but the more
accepted neona feels the more of her
color we allow into the world more color
we filter into every frame and in this
sequence as neumon is giving up hope the
less hope she has the more we pull color
from the frame until that one moment
when she's at her lowest and she's
Yelling to the Sky and moving toward
that sword we literally go black and
white all color comes out of the film
just to help push forward that idea of
where neona is
emotionally we know how important scenes
like this are for kids who feel
misunderstood who feel like on the
outside of their own kingdom to just
tell them they're not
alone from the very first moment ball
meets neona he's asking what are you and
she keeps saying I'm neona all she wants
is to be recognized for for who she is
she doesn't want to explain herself
ballister for the first time in this
journey in this story does actually see
her for who she is for how she wants to
be seen and in that acceptance he calls
her by her name I see you
neona and you're not
alone